es tut mir leid ist jetzt ein bisschen
spät geworden und das ist sicherlich
naja ist ein durcheinander ist nicht
klar dass wir das den hörsaal nicht
verwenden durften hätten also jetzt und
heute und weiter ok jetzt sind avatar
und wir sind noch das thema ist
weiterhin dass kontinuität und
politische philosophie und die
ausgangsfrage ist was ist überhaupt das
kontinuität dieses erstrebenswert wie
soll das jetzt aussehen klassisch
verbindet man diskontinuität mit
revolutionen und da gibt es eine ganze
art folge von revolutionen in der
neuzeit also seit dem 17 jahrhundert die
alle auch von philosophen kommentiert
worden sind wir haben jetzt am ende
begonnen gewisser neuer was heißt ende
weil sie nicht aber ebenfalls im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert mit der
russischen revolution und der reaktion
von linien und dann so verzögert und aus
einer etwas anderen art der reaktion von
carl schmitt
gut also dass ist war der erste punkt
und die frage ist also das dramatische
an der russischen revolution ist oder
jedenfalls so wie es die westeuropäer
verstanden haben also hier wird ein
ganzer staat aufgehoben und von einem
neuen volk quasi oder jedenfalls einer
neuen klasse anders aufgebaut und
installiert und das ist etwas scheinbar
sehr dramatisch ist und das war auch
trainings anspruch gewissermaßen also
der hat ja immer wieder betont wie
gesagt die unversöhnlichkeit zwischen
den der bürgerlichen klasse und der
arbeiterklasse um diese
unversöhnlichkeit ist eben ein zeichen
dafür dass wir alles was kommt radikal
neu ist ein absoluter diskontinuität so
wurde es ebenfalls verstanden und das
lässt sich auch belegen aus lienz
schriften
das wird dann auch von carl schmitt
aufgegriffen
ebenfalls jetzt mit dem anspruch es ist
eine absolute erneuerung es ist ein
nullpunkt ground zero wo etwas ganz
neues wieder anfängt ist die spitze idee
bei uns natürlich ein bisschen anders
ist es nicht die ökonomische klasse der
arbeiter sondern es war das deutsche
volk ok also das sind die die kommentare
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert die haben wir
uns ein bisschen angesehen wie gesagt
die tradition ist aber länger dann
allerdings vor allem im
englischsprachigen bereich
letzte woche haben wir uns hauptamtes
angeschaut
holmes kommentiert die revolution oder
den bürgerkrieg in england zwischen den
royalisten aus dem zweiten und dem
commonwealth vertretern dann also am
ende kam dann kronberg aber warum
krümmel
naja das ist ein anderes thema aber
jedenfalls ist dann die die hawks
kommentar dazu ist das was er letzte
woche uns angeschaut haben und vor allem
eben bei ihm den gedanken dass die macht
oder kraft oder macht jedenfalls power
das entscheidende ist und das ist nicht
schlecht ist es ist ein sich was gutes
und das heißt im politischen bereich des
die das power sich durchsetzen soll
das ist so quasi positiv und die
menschen sollen sich danach richten
können und werden sich danach richten
damit sie auch überleben können und und
gedeihen
im rahmen dieser machtübernahme des
souveräns das ist dann ein kommentar zum
zur revolution zur ersten revolution in
england dann danach kommt dann in ein
weiterer eine weitere kommentierung
durch einen philosophen das ist etwas
berg ihre oder jedenfalls irischer
abstammung obwohl er eigentlich
parlaments abgeordnete in england wurde
und dort auch blieb und burg hat die
zweite revolution selbst eigentlich zwei
revolutionen kommentiert er hat die
zweite englische revolution kommentiert
das ist die glorious revolution von 1688
es der letzte so quasi kathol oder ein
katholischer manar ich mehr oder weniger
vertrieben wurde
james der zweite und ersetzt wurde durch
protestantische eine protestantische
königsfamilie und das ist ein wichtiger
punkt in der politischen entwicklung
england ist es auch ist es immer noch
und die frage ist wie soll man das
verstehen ist das jetzt eine revolution
oder was für eine revolution ist es also
der könig hat mir weiterhin und es gab
auch kaum oder eigentlich gar kein
blutvergießen in dem sinne mit mit der
russischen revolution oder auch mit der
früheren englischen willkommen zu
vergleichen aber das ist jetzt ein thema
bei burg das zweite thema ist dann 100
jahre später etwas weniger die frage
doch 100 jahre 100 1 jahre
die französische revolution naja gut
also dazwischen kam auf die
amerikanische
die hartberg auch ein bisschen
kommentiert aber wichtig und bekannt
dass sind die kommentare ist ein
kommentar zur französischen revolution
reflections um die revolution in front
das habe ich schon benannt
also wie gesagt wir haben mit diesem
also ist aus verschiedenen gründen
natürlich nachvollziehen können ist es
mir lieber wenn man werden wir diese
texte auf englisch behandelt und sie
übersetzungen sind meistens und diesen
als und nicht so verhandeln die
zuverlässig aber jedenfalls also das ist
dann box zweiter eintritt in diese
szenarien okay das ist jetzt das
historisch und ich möchte heute noch ein
bisschen was über oder doch ein bisschen
was über mich sagen ich möchte dann aber
auch als zweiter 2 diskussionspunkt
jetzt mit benjamin beginnen weil sie
möglicherweise das gefühl haben die
leute die bisher zitieren sind alle ein
bisschen unattraktiv ob es jetzt linien
oder carl schmitt oder wen auch immer
oder auch hauptpersonen den und man sich
vielleicht aus eigener präferenz nicht
unbedingt anschließen möchte dagegen ist
benjamin mit guten leumund ist
wahrscheinlich schon einer der zunächst
mal jedenfalls sympathischer wird auch
ich meine das ist sicherlich ein als
moralischer und politischer perspektive
eine ungetrübte quelle
ok also das ist jetzt ein zweites thema
noch mal wir sind jetzt die frage ist
was ist souverän was ist souveränität
was ist autorität wie entsteht diese
autorität im rahmen eines revolutionären
umbruchs das ist die frage
wir haben und wie gesagt das ist eine
frage die internet lexikon auch von
einer eigenen perspektive aus auch
beleuchtet wird also was was ist der das
interface sozusagen die schnittstelle
zwischen der materielle materialität
eines menschen und autorität also
möglicherweise unbegrenzte autorität
oder jedenfalls sehr großer autor sehr
große macht und autorität wie verhält
hat verhalten sich diese beiden faktoren
elemente gut wir haben hier ein modell
letztes mal besprochen
nämlich bei schmidt bei karl schmidt aus
dem juristischen und das modell das das
video gesehen haben ist das was ich als
als dass die thematik der billigkeit
charakterisiert habe also die billigkeit
wie sie sich erinnern ist die komponente
eines richterspruchs die nicht streng
logisch ableitbar ist aus den normen des
gesetzes also es gibt das geschriebene
systematische gesetz aber in der
praktischen anwendung ist das gesetz
meistens nicht eindeutig also das ist
immer so man fantasiert manchmal das
wäre doch schön einen computer zu haben
der streitfälle entscheidet aber so
etwas gibt es nicht und wird es nie
geben weil
der grund warum na ja nicht immer aber
der grund warum man sich überhaupt vor
gericht streitet ist eben weil es keine
eindeutige lösung gibt dann in jedem
fall ist eine komponente der
richterlichen ja einige seiten sagen
willkür aber man sagt einfach die
billigkeit das ist der richter muss
falls beitragen
ansonsten kommt es zu keiner
entscheidung gut und das wird jetzt von
schmidt für seine seinen rezession ismus
verwendet schmidt des zionismus ist die
vorstellung dass letztendlich diese
willkür des richters eigentlich das
determinieren de ist dass ein
richterspruch ist immer unter
determiniert durch das gesetz
deswegen braucht man das den willen des
einzelnen material richters also der
richter ist eine person ohne diese
diesen menschen kommt man zu keiner
entscheidung
und in dem sinne ist der richter oder
ist der wille des richters eigentlich
primär in der konstitution von
gerechtigkeit
er verwendet das gesetz das gesetz ist
quasi ein instrument aber die treibende
kraft und alles was die entscheidung
letztendlich hervorbringt nicht
begründet aber hervorbringt ist der
wille wie gesagt des richtung ist gut
und das wiederum wird von schmidt ins
politische übernommen
das entscheidende ist dann ein wille
irgendein will und weil der wille es
gibt natürlich der wille des volkes
aber wie man sich das vorstellen
es ist etwas obskur und schmidt sagt
daten und
fortsetzung dieses argument na ja
letztendlich wird es dann doch doch
darauf hinauslaufen dass es ein
einzelner mensch ist genau wie der
richter und deswegen sagt er über hitler
hitler ist der höchste richter ist
einfach der richter über das volk und
nicht nur ein richter der sozusagen
passiv da sie zu wartet bis man ihm
probleme probleme zu ihm bringen zum
schlichten sondern er ist auch die
quelle von allem was das volk ausmacht
identität gerechtigkeit und so weiter
und so fort und deswegen kann er auch
bestehen in dem fall nach der langen
messer dass leute hingerichtet ohne
verfahren braucht kein verfahren
er hat in seiner machtfülle oder in
seinem willen ist er der nullpunkt auch
hier also ground zero von dem aus jede
gerechtigkeit entspringt also das ist
ein ein sog war es ein bisschen
juristisches motiv das wird dann auch
verknüpft mit anderen themen der
existenzialisten wie beispielsweise
augenblick das haben wir besprochen also
augenblick ist nicht nur reaktionär
existenzialistisch werden wie wir sehen
werden das ist auch etwas was ein motiv
das bei benjamin vorkommt aber bei
schmidt ist es eben auch augenblick ist
das was nicht in der vorhersehbaren
mechanik der geschichtlichen entwicklung
stecken sondern es ist ausbrechen und
der ort wo ausgebrochen wird ist in dem
fall der wille des führers jetzt
das hat als gegner
zwei elemente oder zwei mögliche
elemente also das eine ist ist das was
schmidt als liberalen rechtsstaat
attackiert der liberale rechtsstaat
glaubt ja es gibt regeln es gibt gesetze
die sind vorrangig die sie haben quasi
einen ursprungs status zuerst kommen die
regeln dann kommt die anwendung
das ist das ist für schmidt der liberale
rechtsstaat ist eine möglichkeit
und das ist etwas was man mit der
tradition der menschenrechte wie es
heißt dort ansiedeln würde gut aber das
ist jetzt im augenblick etwas weniger
interessant eine zweite tradition die
viel länger zurück reicht
na ja in gewissem formen und für schmidt
vielleicht sogar aktueller ist ist das
als ich auch schon erwähnt habe nämlich
die katholische der katholische begriff
der autorität also dieser begriff ist
dann wieder was anderes also bei schmidt
ist es hat man die ist autorität etwas
was spontan aus dem willen des einzelnen
entspringt das ist nicht sehr katholisch
aber die ein grundgedanke der
katholischen kirche theorie ist dass die
katholische kirche eine verkörperung des
göttlichen ist oder jedenfalls 1 1 mit
zum zur vermittlung des göttlichen auf
erden
es ist das ein und dass der ein aspekt
davon ist dass die katholische kirche
auch entwicklungsfähig ist also die
katholische kirche kann sich entwickeln
und muss sich also nicht radikal
verändern
das ist etwas was natürlich mit mit
vorstellungen nicht vereinbar ist oder
auch mit linien nicht also mit dem mit
gerade die die katholische kirche steht
er für kontinuität kontinuität
verkörpert in einer institution die sich
verändern kann also nicht dass diese
diese institution für alle ewigkeit
gleich bleiben muss dann auch nicht dass
alles in dieser situation gut sein muss
aber trotzdem die institution als
gegeben es ist etwas positives
damit kann man arbeiten und die
autorität die von der kirche fli ist ist
begründet in dieser vorstellung dass die
institution an sich etwas gutes ist ja
okay also das ist schmidt war zwar
katholisch aber das ist eher etwas das
er nicht selbst einhalten würde gut
jetzt wo wir sind aber wir sind jetzt
nicht bei der katholischen kirche
sondern wir sind eher bei einer
tradition oder bei gedanken die wir
jetzt bei diesen beiden engländern haben
denn ich hab so dannenberg und das ist
eine quasi säkularisierung des
institutionellen gedankens bei
in der katholischen kirche wie
funktioniert das ja also erstens bei
hobbes wir haben pops anthropologe
philosophische anthropologie letzte
woche besprochen so wo er sagt wie
gesagt also für ihn das ist eine
eigenschaft die einzelnen und auch ein
eigenschaft der politik und das ist was
gutes
also eigentlich eine optimistische welt
anschauen aber wichtiger oder jetzt
relevant für seine politische
darstellung ist eben die figur des
leviathan also leviathan ist kein
monstrum sondern ein künstlicher mensch
also der leviathan dieses diese analogie
eines eines staates ist etwas was der
mensch für sich herstellt es ist keine
tradition
eine tradition die quasi sich aus dem
aus der göttlichen vorsehung schöpft
sondern es ist etwas was die menschen
sich geschaffen haben der leviathan ist
ein künstlicher mensch also wie in dem
bekannten bild auf dem bekannten
umschlag bild von jobs wie otto
leviathan besteht aus einer vielfalt von
menschen also sind viele kleine menschen
und dass man also dass das große level
japan selbst besteht aus diese menschen
also die menschen kreieren ihrem start
ob es jetzt gut oder schlecht oder was
auch immer ist ist ist jetzt
gewissermaßen sekundär
aber ihre macht fließt in diesen staat
ein
und der einzelne verschenkt seine
einzelnen freiheiten gewissermaßen oder
seine eigenen seine eigene power an den
start
und der staat wird hergestellt
willentlich gewollt
absichtlich von den menschen um ihre
power zu kanalisieren so zu sagen okay
also das ist der eine gedanke bei hobbes
also das heißt diese von menschen
hergestellte institutionen ist etwas
positives
das wollen wir haben weil nur dort kommt
die power zum ausdruck und zur anwendung
so also mehr als das sagt er nicht also
das ist jetzt nicht besonders
traditionalistisch bei denkbar ist dass
man jede mögliche variante von leviathan
erstellen könnte und solange die die
power verhältnisse deutlich sind reicht
es gewissermaßen also wie ich letzte
woche schon sagt er bei hobbes sind aber
auch andere menschliche sogar sie halt
moralische elemente dabei die nicht ja
die die eine empirische insistenz haben
es ist nicht nur dass wir dabei anfangen
dass der mensch aus als aus dem
verlangen
das eigene leben zu retten ein vertrag
mit dem leviathan eingeht ich meine das
ist quasi die negativ
der pessimistische aspekt aber positiv
ist wie gesagt im haupt insgesamt power
individuelle power ist was was gutes
versteht das ist das eine das zweite ist
in seiner philosophischen anthropologie
haben die menschen auch bestimmte
eigenschaften die ja analog zu
moralischen vorstellungen sind aber
nicht in irgendwelchen abstrakten
kalkulationen wurzeln
das sind zum einen was ich letzte woche
schon erwähnte die ehre
das und sagt das nicht sehr viel
vielleicht nicht ich weiß es nicht
naja gut wie auch in weißen etwas
altmodischer begriff aber es geht davon
aus dass die menschen mehr gefühl haben
oder haben sollten das war dieses
beispiel mit den mit den mädchen die
sich aufgehängt haben und dann damit
aufgehört haben als sie wussten dass das
die leiche dann entkleidet wird und das
ist eine das wäre dann eine ehrung
selbst nach dem tode
also das ist ein aspekt also erde ein
weiterer aspekt der gewissermaßen damit
zusammenhängt ist die vorstellung dass
man verträge umsetzen muss also wenn man
sich bindet vertraglich dann ist das
eine verpflichtung auf latein pacta sunt
servanda verträge sind umzusetzen
und ja ich meine das ist das ist auch
eine eine vorstellung die mit quasi der
traditionellen moral nicht so wahnsinnig
viel zu tun hat oder nur indirekt aber
in diesem bereich eine wichtige rolle
spielt auch bei wagner über können
pacta sunt servanda das ist ja etwas was
bei im ring sondern eine rolle spielt
gut aber das ist jetzt alles anders aber
jedenfalls bei hobbes wie gesagt die
gedanken ihre und die verbindlichkeit
von verträgen
das sind elemente die in seine in seine
vorstellung einfließen gut aber mehr
nicht das ist relativ
bescheiden was was was da an inhalt
moralischen inhalten kommt so jetzt
haben wir aber burg und was ist mit
bergwerk ist wie gesagt dieser irische
denker der dann in diesem schreiben also
was ich jetzt auch in die folie gesetzt
habe das sind seine kommentare star aus
dem aus dem aus der schrift über die
französische revolution aber eigentlich
geht es hier um diesen stellen um die
englische revolution von vor 100 jahren
und die klare vision von 1688 und da
geht es um die frage ja was ist dann
was entsteht aus einer revolution ist
eine revolution etwas was die welt von
oben bis unten erneuert oder nicht oder
speziell jetzt was war dies das war
diese englische sogenannte revolution
und dann ist da sagt berg es gab zwei
möglichkeiten also 1688 als james
derzeit quasi dem katholizismus
verfallen war das war das den der
eindruck der in der engländer zu dieser
zeit und man dachte ja gut wir haben uns
von diesen katholischen elementen
freigekämpft in den im laufe der letzten
100 jahre das ist jetzt aus der
perspektive der engländer in 1688 und
wir wollen jetzt keinen englischen
keinen katholischen fürsten also wenn
der james katholisch sein will dann muss
er das woanders mal dann okay okay
heutzutage kann man das jetzt nicht ohne
weiteres nachvollziehen dass man das so
ernst nehmen minute aber damals war es
sehr wichtig natürlich nur ein teil
aber die frage war was machen wir jetzt
wenn wir unseren monarchischen feuern
oder geht das überhaupt oder was heißt
das es gibt hier ein schritt zurück
erwidert hier an diesen scheiben auf
einen takt von einem protestantischen
geist geist geistlichen preis der die
französische revolution als quasi
nachholung dessen was die engländer vor
100 jahren gemacht hatten
in dem sinne dass das eine radikale
erneuerung jetzt meisten wir die taffen
raus also sehr anti katholisch war die
französische revolution war jedenfalls
zu beginn ziemlich an
kirchlich und das wurde dann
aufgegriffen von diesen drei
protestantischen pfarrer in england der
behauptet hat ja die jetzt machen die
franzosen das was sie vor 100 jahren
getan haben und schmeißen die
katholische kirche works und das und das
was danach kommt ist dann total neu und
frisch und unberührt uns weiter und das
ist was beck kritisiert und er sagt es
gibt zwar theoretisch die möglichkeit
dass das parlament es ging ja um das
parlament damals sechs 1688 also der der
james haben mehr oder weniger geflohen
das parlament musste dann entscheiden ja
was machen wir jetzt und was ist was ist
die autorität überhaupt wo finden die
cia oder wien soll wieder einsetzen und
berg sagt es ist denkbar
theoretisch kann man sich das vorstellen
dass hier ein absoluter neubeginn
gewesen wäre und er sagt das ist in dem
langen zitat auf der ersten seite von
der folie mehr abstract kompetenz of the
supreme aber das ist jetzt die 17 teile
von diesen langen zitat die limits to
the abstract kompetenz of the supreme
power also prima ist ja das parlament
und ist er sagt also wenn man sich das
jetzt überlegt abstrakt gesehen gibt es
überhaupt einschränkungen für eine
souveräne macht also denn das parlament
jetzt wie nach der englischen instituts
verfassung ist das parlament so verehren
damals auch schon und wenn man da ist
auch das parlament ist souverän was
wären dann die einschränkungen
eigentlich gar keine oder ist es sehr
schwer diese einschränkung diese grenzen
der macht zu bezeichnen
also es ist dvb hubs impossible limits
to the abstract kompetenz of the supreme
power also abstrakt gesehen kann das
parlament alles machen aber besorgt bei
und das ist halt nicht was passierte
die haben da hatten wir haben nicht eine
abstrakte kompetenz ausgeübt sondern und
das ist der zweite satz hälfte jetzt
kommt ein teil von dem satz das müssen
sie das hat keinen sinn dass ich das
vorlese aber es geht jetzt nicht im
gegensatz zum abstract kompetenz geht es
um moral kompetenz und morgen kompetenz
dass das limit also das dass man das
definieren und einschränken kann ist
eigentlich oder fast selbstverständlich
oder jedenfalls ist dass wir dann später
paar zeilen später sagt intelligence
perfectly binding up on the exercise and
storage also das kann man sich schon gut
vorstellen das ist intelligence ist
völlig verständlich also dass ist
moralische limits gibt für das parlament
das ist versteht sich von selbst und das
hat das so hat das parlament damals
gehandelt anliegt gesagt naja wir
schmeißen alles aus dem fenster aus den
souveränen den monarchen haben wir jetzt
nicht mehr die brauchen wir nicht mehr
jetzt fangen wir bei adam wieder an und
machen etwas ganz neues dann ist
bürgschaft dazu also man könnte sich das
so vorstellen vielleicht aber
tatsächlich war es nicht so es macht
keinen sinn jetzt völlig abstrakt sich
vollzieht er die kompetenz des
parlaments ja schon die kompetenz
abstrakt gesehen war die kompetenz
uneingeschränkt aber tatsächlich gab es
einschränkungen und die entsprechenden
dieser moralische kompetenz okay was
heißt jetzt moralische kompetenz
das ist nicht ganz damit ist nicht
gemeint jetzt moral im sinne von gutes
benehmen sondern und dann geht es weiter
und jetzt kommt es kommt wieder ein
juristisches modell bis sozusagen im
gegensatz zu schnitt man sich vorstellen
kann
und er sagt einen satz jetzt weiter der
haus auf los fünftens ist ein
kompetentes nach uns kommen also die das
oberhaus house los ist nicht moralisch
kompetenz des unterhaus nach hause
kommen es aufzulösen
ja also das beschreibt er als moralische
einschränkung es gibt im hause globes
und die house los ist gewissermaßen zu
verändern teil des souveräns jedenfalls
aber das haus laut kann nicht
beispielsweise das unterhaus auflösen
warum nicht naja gut ein moment die
frage beantworten wir gleich aber zuerst
kann das haus slot kann das nicht machen
euro und dann der zweite hälfte des
satzes not even to deserve it service
kann sich selber nicht auf
also wirksam
in diesem fall kann die quelle der
autorität alles machen nur nicht sich
selber auflösen
also das geht nicht und sagte auch jetzt
weiter decade for his augen passen wie
keiner ernte kate vätermonate das heißt
ein krieg ein kind der könig kann schon
ab treten wie es ja passiert ist
gewisser mal also dass man hat nämlich
james den zweiten also das heißt james
gemacht hat der ist wie gesagt geflohen
oder wenig aber das hat man dann also
ausgelegt als ein abtreten
ja das hätte mehr oder weniger da zum
ausdruck gebracht dass er nicht länger
könig sein wollte
das kann schon machen aber er kann nicht
die institution der monarchie dadurch
auflösen
also das geht dann weiter ok also das
ist jetzt wie gesagt eigentlich ein
klassischer gedanke sowohl juristisch
als auch in der politik also juristisch
ist der gedanke dass also das bekannt
unter dem begriff von juristischen
personen also mit einschränkungen aber
eine juristische person ist nicht
unbedingt abhängig von den mitgliedern
von den gesellschaftern oder egal was es
ist eine juristische person wäre
beispielsweise ein
bürgerliche gesellschaft und einer
bürger naja gut sagen wir lieber eine
aktiengesellschaft eine
aktiengesellschaft hat dauert fort auch
wenn die aktionäre ersetzen
im englischen recht gibt es dafür ein
noch deutlicheres modell wollen einen
einer aktiengesellschaft kann abhängig
von den von der mitgliedschaft schon
aufgelöst werden aufgelöst werden
im englischen recht gibt es ein anderes
modell nämlich der trust oder die
stiftung aber eher eine deutsche
stiftung ist nicht direkt das selbe wie
in englischer trust aber entschärft ist
eine institution die nicht abhängig ist
von einem aktiven betreiber also ein
trust hat zwei wesentliche komponenten
das eine ist es hat vermögen also
irgendein stifter kommt und schenkt
vermögen an den tropf und der gast
braucht dann auch begünstigt dass
irgendjemand muss davon profitieren
nicht der stifter anderen leute das ist
alles was man braucht und leute die
quasi den fast managen
die heißen auf englisch krusty ist oder
sind die verwalter die sind beliebig
austauschbar und auch wenn alle
plötzlich in einem
flugzeugabsturz umkommen das zerstört
den gast nicht also solange der tat noch
vermögen und begünstigt da hat dann ist
sind die leute die die den fonds
verwaltet beliebig austauschbar
ok also das ist jetzt dieser gedanke der
hiermit sind bei berg ebenfalls eine
juristische vorstellung also bei schnitt
war es der gedanke ja was eigentlich
bezeichnend ist ist die der wille der
entscheidung wille des richters was
sicherlich auch stimmt aber macht es
sich selber zu nutzer für seine
intention ist muss bei berg ist es jetzt
ein anderes eine andere figur aus der
juristerei nämlich der gedanke der
institution die fortdauert auch wenn die
mitglieder der institution ersetzt
werden oder oder wegfahren ok und bei
der monarchie ist das ist das natürlich
ein klassisches beispiel also wie es
immer heißt also wenn der könig stirbt
der könig ist tot es lebe der könig also
sind natürlich zwei könige also der alte
könig ist tot es lebe der könig also ist
es die die die die institution an sich
dauert fort auch wenn die einzelnen
vertreter oder inhaber der der rolle
ersetzt werden ok gut also dass ist
jetzt ein punkt und burg zu burg ist
kommentiert ja auch sehr konservative
art und weise ich meine das ist schon
klar das ist jetzt quasi gegnerschaft
aber es ist auch wichtig für benjamin
das werde ich jetzt ich weiß nicht ob
ich heute noch dazukommen aber benjamin
ist übernimmt ganz wichtige elemente der
tradition also für birg jedenfalls also
er nimmt er beschreibt seine these als
kritische mary kritischen tripolis und
kritisiert tradition ist eben der
gedanke ist gibt von die fundamentalen
elemente des des menschlichen
zusammenseins dauern fort unabhängig von
den einzelnen akteuren und das ist etwas
was ich schon bei hobbes hatten also
dass radikale bei hobbes es war eben der
gedanke des künstlichen menschen der
staat ist etwas von menschen konzipiert
und zusammengesetzt
unabhängig von gott und eigentlich
unabhängig von unmittelbaren
machtverhältnissen also der leviathan
ist die positive erscheinung der
gemeinsamen macht
okay gut und das ist etwas was bei berg
auch kommt also hobbs ist jetzt
tradition nicht traditionalistisch aber
gewissermaßen das kann man so auslegen
bei burg ist es dann ausdrücklich so
dass diese künstlichen errungenschaften
das menschliche menschlichen
zusammenlebens die sind auch eine
radikale base ist für die menschen also
es ist dann um hinterfragbar auch von
revolutionären also auch die revolution
die kommt die kann man zwar sich
vorstellen als einen radikal neuen
zahlen aber das ist eine illusion ist
ist nicht so weil die menschen befinden
sich immer noch innerhalb des leviathan
es auch wenn der leviathan sich
verändert und vor allem die menschen die
im leviathan der sagen haben delegiert
haben selbst dauert fort ok und dann
also berg sagt auch nicht also wie das
ist auch eine popstars element er sagt
ausdrücklich nicht dass die englische
monarchie irgendwie das die beste lösung
für alles ist und es muss man haben und
super institution und so weiter sagt
einfach also so wie wir das haar munser
leviathan sozusagen ist eine
erbmonarchie dachte ja also heute ist
das in dem sind jetzt eigentlich gar
nicht mehr richtig dass das nicht mehr
zu aber da und auch schon damals bei
park war die tatsächliche macht des
königs in dem fall georg des dritten
also sehr eingeschränkt er hatte schon
mehr zu sagen als heutzutage die queen
aber aber entscheidend waren dann war
dann in dem in diesem teil alltag schon
dass der prämierten premierminister der
seine eigene regierung zusammenstellen
konnte aber trotzdem burg sagt unser
leviathan unser englisch leviathan
basiert auf einer im monat
und dieser erbmonarchie können wir quasi
verfolgen will sehen wie das durch die
menschen erstellt wurde und er sagt
bezieht sich dann auf konkrete gesetze
und konkrete entscheidung
er sagt das ist das zitat auf der
zweiten seite von einer folie also die
erbfolge der krone
und er weist darauf hin also man hat
also früher war das quasi
selbstverständlich und unausgesprochen
das ist die leiblichen nachkommen waren
der könig also könig hat in dem fall so
bis dahin gab es noch oder gar doch ich
glaube ich auch eine königin aber
generell waren es also bis elisabeth
jedenfalls waren es männer aber wie auch
elizabeth war ja die tochter von
heinrich den achten also leibliche
nachkommen und das war dann das gemeine
recht also das unausgesprochene gemeinde
recht in der leviathan irgendwann über
sie hatten die menschen entschieden wir
machen es so engländer hatten
entschieden wir machen es so und das ist
das aber keiner wusste waren oder es war
nicht niedergeschrieben sondern es war
das gemeine recht kommen lockt und
später hat man das musste man eingreifen
sein leviathan ein bisschen uns
funktionieren oder kleine änderungen
machen und das ist etwas sagt berg was
ein paar jahre nach der glorious
revolution von 1688 als das parlament
sagt okay es ist jetzt ein bisschen
schwierig
wer soll jetzt die hat nämlich keine
kinder
wer soll als nächstes kommen und dann
hat man gesagt als nächstes kommt die
das wahnsinnig kompliziert aber ich habe
das jetzt die einzelne leute habe ich
jetzt vergessen aber ich glaube es waren
zuerst aber in zu diesem zeitpunkt 1700
oder 1701 musste sich das parlament
gedanken machen
okay wir sind eine eine konstitution the
crown eine die krone wird in als erfolge
weitergereicht aber wer kommt jetzt als
nächstes wollen wir haben keine
nachkommen von mary und wir haben zwar
viele nachkommen auf mit katholischer
ausrichtung aber das wollen wir ja nicht
und dann hat man entschieden in diesem
gesetz 1717 101
zunächst kommt das war die tochter von
james dem zweiten der beschafft wurde
war aber protestantisch sie hatten sie
hatte aber auch keine kinder und danach
sollten es also die kinder der
kurfürstin sophia von hannover sein
wieso jetzt auf einmal eine deutsche
prinzessin
die antwort ist dass ihre mutter deren
namen ich vergessen habe aber jedenfalls
die mutter von der sofia war die tochter
von james den ärzten ok und die sie war
die
frau vom winterkönig dem pfälzer
kurfürsten der 1620 zu beginn des
dreißigjährigen krieges von seinem thron
vertrieben wurde
aber das ehepaar hat sich dann nach
holland glaube ich abgesetzt und deren
tochter war die sophia die dann den
kurfürsten von hannover
geheiratet hat
und übrigens nicht nur die sofia hat
nicht nur den kurfürsten von hannover
geheiratet sondern sie war auch
philosophisch aktiv weil sie leibnitz
potenziert hat
ok also jedenfalls ihre kinder oder ihre
leiblichen abkommen sollten dann sofern
sie protestantisch waren das war eine
wichtige einschränkung fortan die
erfolge der krone bilden und daher kam
der erste georg als als er gestorben ist
1714 kam der kurfürst georg aus hannover
und wurde könig von england
so ist es okay gut aber das argument
hier ist berg sagt es gibt diese
strukturen die einerseits schon
menschlicher herkunft sind also das ist
kein argument hier dass gott das gewollt
hat oder sonst was also keine kleine
katholische thematik sondern es ist eine
institution die von menschen erdacht und
uns eingesetzt wurde nämlich dieser
leviathan und daran es ist es menschlich
man kann es weil es menschlich ist kann
man es auch ändern indem man
beispielsweise dieses gesetz über die
erfolge
entscheidet also da hat mal gesagt also
wir wollen jetzt die leiblichen
nachkommen von der kurve ist in sofia
haben
die hätten genauso gut sagen können die
leiblichen abkommen von james im zweiten
da gab es nämlich genug leute es gab
nämlich jahre danach die erste hälfte
des 18ten jahrhunderts hat viele
versuche gesehen von anderen intendanten
leute die gesagt haben wir haben den
besseren besseren anspruch als dieser
georg aus hannover vor allem die
schottischen praktische prinzen
gut also dass hätten die ich schon sagen
können aber jedenfalls ist zwar möglich
dass die entscheidung zu entscheiden
also wir haben zeit grundsätzlich diese
struktur der der leiblichen erfolge aber
wir sagen wir wollen jetzt die die
abkommen von der prinzessin sofia und
sie sollen auch protestantisch sein
das heißt es ist von menschen geschaffen
und kann von menschen geändert werden
aber ja das ist der erste punkt der
zweite kunden ist wie gesagt diese
vorstellung dass das eine grundlage
bildet es ist quasi transzendentale
bedingungen der politischen betätigung
jedenfalls in england jedenfalls im
siebzehnten jahrhundert oder beginnt das
örtliche jahrhunderts also das ist der
gedanke ist ein bisschen hobbs weil es
ist der gedanke ja die menschen haben
das erschaffen ein bisschen allerdings
mehr als das war halb hamburg so quasi
auch eine eine erkenntnis theoretisches
element einbaut oder ein transzendentale
das element einbaut indem man sagt ja
und das ist die bedingung unter dr
politischer aktivität sich in england
überhaupt entwickeln konnte damals ja
insofern revolution ja aber nur eine
modifikation innerhalb von fest
stehenden traditionen ja okay und dann
ja gut also die das dritte zitat auf
einer folie ist ist das eine
wiederholung desselben gut also jetzt
möchte ich noch eine bemerkung also
benjamin wird uns ein bisschen mehr
beschäftigen
aber ich möchte jetzt noch zu benjamin
schnell ein leid und was sagen in diesem
zusammenhang und benjamins zitate sind
auch auf dieser folie also bei benjamin
zunächst mal haben wir elemente die es
sehr stark an heiliger abschnitt
erinnern wichtig eben ist die saga dank
dieser gedanke der des augenblicks also
auch für benjamin gibt es eine
unterbrechung der kontinuität und
benennt die heißt bei ihm wie bei den
anderen auch augenblick also augenblick
ist die das was nicht mehr in der zeit
ist es ist quasi geschichtlich benjamin
sagt benjamin aber nicht in der zeit vor
allem ist es nicht teil des
kontinuierlichen fortschritt also
fortschritt ist das sagt er
eine eine illusion das problem mit den
sozialisten bisher war immer dass sie an
fortschritt fortschritt glauben aber da
deswegen haben sie quasi die eigene
freiheit oder oder
aktions möglichkeit aus der hand gegeben
vor allem jetzt sind sie dem faschismus
zu opfer zum opfer geworden und deswegen
brauchen wir ein ausbrechen daraus und
das nennt benjamin wie schon karl
schmidt einen augenblick aber jetzt die
die das wichtige oder würde dass er sich
jetzt ihnen heute sagen wollte und das
werden wir dann im detail nächstes mal
besprechen ist benjamins gedanke oder
bänder mit beruft sich hierbei auch auf
tradition
ja ich zögere bis sie weil es vielleicht
doch ein zu großes thema ist für die
vier jetzt aber ich möchte sie trotzdem
noch darauf hinweisen wir können dann
ein nächstes mal überlegen genau wie das
zu verstehen ist benjamins idee ist es
wissen sie wahrscheinlich schon ist in
diesem augenblick des verstehens oder
das augenblick der geschichte wo man aus
bricht aus der kontinuität rettet man
sich vor einer gefahr
das hatten wir auch bei schmidt
natürlich es im augenblick der gefahr
dass die genau diese phrase kommt ja
auch bei schmidt vor bei schmidt
schaltet sich der führer dann ein
bei benjamin im augenblick der gefahr
ist dass man sich erinnert an etwas in
der vergangenheit das uns befreit
aus diesem kontinuum das ist wichtig
also es ist jetzt benjamin spricht zwar
von einer konstruktion
also wir gehen in die zukunft auf eine
konstruktive art und weise aber das ist
wie schon bei berg nicht eine radikale
neukonstruktion
sondern es ist ein solid eine
solidarität mit einem element der
vergangenheit und er sagt beispielsweise
die was ist die gefahr welche arten von
gefahr sind es die wir im augenblick der
gefahr uns bewusst werden sagt die
gefahr droht sowohl dem bestand der
tradition wie ihren empfängern
das ist wichtig wenn benjamin tradition
hier erwähnt dann ist es genau auch die
tradition die burg meint würde ich mal
vorschlagen das können wir dann im
nächsten mal ein bisschen näher
besprechen aber benjamin beruft sich auf
tradition also für ihn ist quasi ist es
dass die erinnerung an ein befreiungsakt
zum beispiel aus der vergangenheit also
in dieser eine tradition derart also ein
eine tradition etwas wo wo die menschen
schon mal auf mehr oder weniger
heroische art und weise vielleicht oder
sich geopfert haben
wie auch immer und das ist das
bezeichnet er als tradition das ist in
den
zum begriff der geschichte und er sagt
auch vergleich das auch das bewusstsein
das kontinuum der geschichte
aufzuspringen ist den revolutionären
klassen im augenblick ihrer aktion
eigentümlich und er sagt der tag mit dem
ein kalender einsetzt fungiert als ein
historischer zeitraffer und es ist im
grunde genommen
derselbe tag der in gestalt der
feiertage die tage des ein gedenkens
sind immer wiederkehrt also das ist
jetzt wieder diese diese thematik aus
als das erinnern dass ein gedenken
eingedenk an wie gesagt die opfer der
[Musik]
unterdrückten kasse in der vergangenheit
zum beispiel und das ist was ganz
anderes als das was bei schmitt im
augenblick der gefahr hoch kommt also
bei schmidt ist es eben der tatkräftige
führer der das volk rettet bei benjamin
nein das funktioniert anders das ist
dieses das müssen wir dann im einzelnen
besprechen aber ist es dann ebenfalls 1
er sagt aktualisiere einer vergangenen
befreiungs tat und das ist eine
tradition die vergleichbar ist auch mit
den traditionen die burg bespricht aber
das ist
dieser brückenschlag ist wahrscheinlich
jetzt für die zeit die ich mir jetzt
genommen hat zu groß das werden wir
nächste woche ein bisschen besprechen so
ok ich höre jetzt auf und wenn sie
fragen haben dann bitte melden sie sich